This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedanta. In February 2024, two German tourists visited Australia. During one section of their trip in Queensland, they turned off the main road on the advice of Google Maps. They figured that the road up ahead was closed because of a rising river and the detour would take them to their destination. As one of them put it later, they trusted the map. We decided, okay, let's follow Kulmer, because Kulmer knows maybe more than we know.
这里是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔。2024年2月，两名德国游客游览了澳大利亚。在昆士兰州的一段行程中，他们听从了谷歌地图的建议，驶离了主路。他们觉得前方道路因河水上涨而封闭，走这条绕路可以到达目的地。正如其中一人后来所说，他们信任这个地图。我们决定，好吧，那就跟着库尔默走，因为库尔默可能比我们知道得更多。
The tourists told an Australian TV station and other media that they took a dirt path known as the Langi Track. At first, things looked fine. Their off-road vehicle seemed up for the terrain. But about 40 miles in, the four-wheel drive Nissan Navara got bogged down. Its wheels sank into the mud. The Germans were stuck and they found they couldn't reach anyone for help. Recognizing they were in serious trouble, they decided to abandon their vehicle and
这两名游客告诉澳大利亚的一家电视台和其他媒体，他们走了一条被称为兰吉小径的泥土路。起步时，一切看起来都很正常。他们的越野车似乎能够应付这种地形。但在行驶了大约40英里后，这辆四轮驱动的日产纳瓦拉陷入了困境。它的车轮陷进了泥里。德国人被困住了，他们发现无法联系到任何人寻求帮助。意识到自己陷入了严重的困境，他们决定弃车，
trek back in the direction they'd come. I feel like in a movie, like in a bad movie, we tried to build a shelter, but that didn't work really well. So we slept like under the sky. Rain poured down on them. They had to watch out for pigs and snakes and crocodiles. The 40-mile journey took several days. The tourists made it back safely. Rangers later helped them retrieve their vehicle. But they had learned an important lesson.
沿着来时的方向艰难折返。我感觉就像在电影里，就像在一部烂电影里，我们试图搭建一个避难所，但效果真的不太好。所以我们就在露天睡觉。大雨倾盆而下。他们必须提防野猪、蛇和鳄鱼。这40英里的旅程花了几天时间。游客们安全返回了。护林员后来帮他们找回了车辆。但他们吸取了一个深刻的教训。
A map that's wrong can sometimes be worse than no map at all. In today's episode and in a companion story on our subscription feed Hidden Brain Plus, we explore the maps inside our own heads. What happens when these maps, which we have constructed ourselves, lead us astray? Misdirection, minds, and, to imagine how things will go. But life often has other plans in store for us. What happens then? Norman Farb is a psychologist and neuroscientist at the University of Toronto. Over many years, he has studied how we plan for the future and what happens when our plans are derailed.
一张错误的地图有时甚至比没有地图还要糟糕。在今天的节目中以及我们付费订阅频道《隐藏脑plus》的一期配套故事中，我们将探讨我们脑海中的地图。当我们自己构建的这些地图将我们引入歧途时，会发生什么？方向误导、思想，以及对事情发展走向的想象。但生活往往为我们另有安排。那会怎么样呢？诺曼·法布是多伦多大学的一名心理学家和神经科学家。多年来，他一直在研究我们如何规划未来，以及当我们的计划被打破时会发生什么。
Norman Farb, welcome to Hidden Brain. Thanks so much, Shankar. It's really a pleasure to be here. Norm, your maternal grandparents were born in Poland. They were Jewish and they experienced the horrors of the Holocaust. After surviving the concentration camps, they moved to Canada to start a new life. They knew what they wanted for their daughter. This is your mother, Linda. Tell me about the world your grandparents constructed for her.
诺曼·法布，欢迎来到《隐藏的大脑》。非常感谢，尚卡尔。很高兴能来到这里。诺姆，你的外祖父母出生在波兰。他们是犹太人，经历了犹太人大屠杀的恐怖。在从集中营幸存下来后，他们搬到加拿大开始了新的生活。他们清楚地知道他们想为女儿做些什么。这就是你的母亲琳达。跟我讲讲你外祖父母为她构建的世界吧。
Yeah, so they wanted things to be very safe for their children. As you might imagine, there's literally no extended family. They're the sole survivors of both their family trees. For their daughter, they brought with them the somewhat antiquated view that her job was to be a really good girl growing up, be a help to her mother, and then find someone to marry and manage a household. And I think she really internalized that. If she just was a good girl and married a nice man and had a good household, then life would turn out just great for her and she would be happy. Linda's life didn't turn out the way her parents imagined. She and Norm's father fought.
是的，所以他们希望孩子们的生活非常安全。正如你所想象的那样，这里简直没有大家庭。他们是各自家族仅存的幸存者。对于他们的女儿，他们带来了一种多少有些过时的观点，即她的职责是做一个成长中的真正的好女孩，做她母亲的帮手，然后找个人结婚并操持家务。我想她真的把这一点内化了。如果她只是做一个好女孩，嫁一个好男人，拥有一个幸福的家庭，那么她的生活就会对她很好，她也会很幸福。琳达的生活并没有像她的父母想象的那样发展。她和诺姆的父亲吵架了。
her parents imagined. She and Norm's father fought. I remember growing up in a period where there would be calm, but then also really stormy periods where my parents are fighting a lot. Ultimately, that led to their divorce right around the time I left for university. By the time I was done, my undergraduate days, my parents had completely split and my mother was living on her own. This was a catastrophic change in the narrative that she expected for herself. Talk about that. I mean, she was raised with the notion that if she was a good daughter, a good wife, a good mother, that was the responsibility she had, and in turn, she would be looked after, she would have security, she would have stability. And in some ways, she had done her part, but life had massive disruption of the story she expected for herself
她的父母想象的那样。她和诺姆的父亲吵架了。我记得在我成长的那个时期，会有平静的时候，但也会有非常暴风雨般的时期，我的父母经常吵架。最终，这导致了他们在我就读大学前后的离婚。当我完成本科学业时，我的父母已经彻底分居了，我的母亲独自一人生活。对于她为自己期望的生活轨迹来说，这是一个灾难性的变化。谈谈这个吧。我的意思是，她受到的教育观念是，如果她是一个好女儿、好妻子、好母亲，这就是她肩负的责任，而作为回报，她会得到照顾，她会拥有安全感，她会拥有稳定性。在某些情况下，她尽了自己的职责，但生活对她期望的故事造成了巨大的颠覆，
and for the way her life unfolded. And she lapsed into a deep depression. So she would tell me in these phone calls that she felt like, you know, it was just unbelievable that her life had turned out this way. We would talk on average once a week and go into these really deep, soul-searching conversations where she tried to explain to me why she didn't deserve this, that someone was supposed to take care of her and what was going to happen to her now. Often she'd be in tears, so really emotionally dysregulated and upset and sad. With that sadness was this urge to make sense of what had happened, that she had done her best but it wasn't good enough and it was unfair and just really unreasonable.
并且打破了她生活展开的方式。她陷入了深深的抑郁之中。所以在这些电话里，她会告诉我，她觉得，你知道的，她的生活竟然会变成这样，简直令人难以置信。我们平均每周通话一次，并进行这些非常深刻、触及灵魂的对话，她试图向我解释为什么她不该承受这一切，本来应该有人照顾她，而她现在该怎么办。她经常泪流满面，所以在情绪上真的很失调、沮丧且悲伤。伴随着这种悲伤的是一种想要弄清楚发生了什么的冲动，她已经尽力了，但这还不够，这太不公平了，而且真的很不合理。
It was just so almost incomprehensible that life had turned out this way, almost like an unwillingness to accept that she was now single and living on her own and isolated. So by this point, you had started to study psychology. So you were learning about ideas about the mind and the brain. And I'm wondering, did you try and share with her the things that you were learning, the models you were learning about human behavior? I've been studying a lot of things around existentialism and people negotiating their own meaning in life on the philosophy side. And I've been studying psychology and about how people make meanings for themselves and how much we construct
生活竟然会变成这样，几乎是如此不可思议，几乎就像是不愿意接受她现在单身、独居并且孤立无援的事实。所以在这一点上，你已经开始研究心理学了。所以你正在了解有关心灵和大脑的想法。我想知道，你是否曾试图与她分享你正在学习的东西，你正在了解的关于人类行为的模型？我在哲学方面学习了很多关于存在主义和人们在生活中协商自身意义的事物。我一直在研究心理学，关于人们如何为自己创造意义，以及我们在多大程度上构建了
our own narratives of our lives. So I would try to reason with her and say, okay, these things happen, but can we see from a practical point of view that the more time you spend rehearsing all of these hurts, these slings and arrows from the past, the more you end up suffering as though they are still happening. And this is where these conversations would take 30, 40, 50 minutes. And there were times I really felt like at an intellectual level, she's following me, my mother's a bright woman as well, and would be able to say, I see this, I see this. Maybe I should stop focusing so much on what your father did. And then there'd be a pause. But you know
我们自己生活的叙事。所以我试图与她讲道理，并说，好吧，这些事情已经发生了，但从实际的角度来看，我们难道不能明白，你花在重温所有这些伤痛、来自过去的投枪和投矛上的时间越多，你最终遭受的痛苦就好像它们仍在发生一样。这就是这些对话需要花费30、40、50分钟的地方。有几次我真的觉得在理智层面上，她能跟上我的思路，我母亲也是个聪明的女人，并且能够说，我明白了，我明白了。也许我不应该把那么多精力放在你父亲做过的事情上。然后会有一段停顿。但你知道
what he did this other time. It was almost like it didn't really matter if there was some sort of intellectual understanding. This rupture of her model of the world was so catastrophic that it had a gravity of itself that just demanded her attention. When she wasn't effortfully thinking about something, it would just suck her right back into this litany of slights and hurts and wrongs. And I'm wondering from your part, it's difficult at any age to be handling a situation like this, but at 20 it must have been especially difficult. But did you feel, you know, I'm giving my mom good advice, she really should listen to me, it clearly does make sense to live in the present and not in the past.
他之前做过的那件事。这几乎就像是否存在某种理智上的理解并不重要一样。她对世界模型的这种破裂是如此灾难性，以至于它具有一种自身的引力，强行要求她去关注。当她不是刻意去想某事时，它就会把她直接拉回这种细数冷落、伤害和错误陈词滥调中。我想知道从你的角度来看，在任何年龄段处理这样一种情况都是困难的，但在20岁时一定尤其困难。但你有没有觉得，你知道的，我在给妈妈提好的建议，她真的应该听我的，活在当下而不是过去显然是合乎情理的。
And were you frustrated in some ways that she was not learning from you or taking your advice? Yeah, I think I moved from a position of, you know, benevolent intentions and a conviction that we're going to get through this together and we're going to figure out how to pick up the pieces to a sort of first frustration that the way out of this cell that you're in, like the door is open here, there's a roomy quote, the door to your cell is open, why don't you go through? And I remember
而且你是否在某种程度上感到沮丧，因为她没有向你学习或听取你的建议？是的，我想我从一个抱着善良的意图、坚信我们一定会携手度过难关、我们会想办法收拾残局的位置，转变成了一种最初的沮丧——你身处的那间牢房的出路就在这里，门其实是开着的，引用一句鲁米的话，你牢房的门是开着的，你为什么不走出去呢？我记得
just getting so frustrated thinking like, we've been here before, we've gone through this reasoning, you've recognized that what you're doing is harmful to yourself and perpetuating your suffering, and you agree that it would be better to do something else and then yet you persist. And up to this point where I really started to resent the interactions and I just didn't want to have this role anymore of being her counselor. Like I put in my time and it just wasn't working despite trying to be inventive and approach it at different angles. I remember if the phone would ring on the weekend at the time when she would normally
当时感到无比沮丧，心想：我们以前也经历过这种情况，我们已经进行过这种推理，你已经认识到你的所作所为对你自己是有害的，并且在延续你的痛苦，你也同意做点别的会更好，然而你却依然执迷不悟。直到后来，我真的开始对这些互动产生怨恨，我再也不想扮演她心理咨询师的角色了。就像我已经付出了时间和精力，但尽管我一直在努力创新并从不同的角度去接近它，却依然不管用。我记得当时如果在周末听到电话铃声响起，而这通常是她
call starting to feel this real negative feeling in my body, like an aversion or repulsion almost and at the same time being like, oh, what's happening now? I feel like my relationship with my mother, my own mental health is being compromised by being drawn into this rumination pattern over and over again. What seems to me at this point that both of you in some ways had come up with maps, she had a map for how her life was going to turn out and was really upset that the map did not seem to conform with the reality of her life. And you had a map of how you could help her and how psychology could help her. And when she did not follow that map, you were getting frustrated.
打电话的时间，我的身体就会开始产生这种真正的负面感觉，几乎是一种厌恶或抗拒，与此同时又觉得，天哪，现在又怎么了？我觉得我和母亲的关系、我自己的心理健康，正因为一次又一次地被卷入这种反刍思维的模式而受到损害。此时在我看来，你们两个人在某种程度上都提出了地图，她有一张关于她的生活将如何发展的地图，并且对这张地图似乎不符合她生活的现实感到非常沮丧。而你有一张关于你如何能够帮助她以及心理学如何能够帮助她的地图。当她没有按照那张地图去做时，你便开始感到沮丧。
In some ways, both of you had these maps and were upset that real life was not conforming to them. I think so. At the time, I would have said it was all about her map being, her holding onto her map. But I did have this insight at one point that also I was starting to fall into my own sort of script, right? And that I had a map of being the smart, you know, helpful son who is going to help pull her out of her depression and that I was going to fix her in some way. And so there was just, as you said, actually two violations. There's the violation of her narrative of being cared
在某些方式上，你们俩都有这些地图，并且对现实生活没有符合这些地图感到沮丧。我想是的。当时，我会说这完全是因为她的地图，是因为她紧抓着她的地图不放。但我在某个时刻确实有了这样一个洞察：我也开始陷入我自己的某种剧本中，对吧？我有一张要成为一个聪明、你知道的、乐于助人的儿子的地图，我要帮她走出抑郁，我要以某种方式修复她。正如你所说，实际上存在着两种违背。一是违背了她余生都被人照顾、婚姻幸福美满地继续下去的叙事——尽管这很理想主义。二是对我作为好儿子的效能的违背，我本要通过我纯粹的智谋来帮助她并把她从困境中拉出来。我意识到我也在按照一个剧本行事。我扮演心理分析师、推着她去改变、推着她去接受某些事实的剧本，其结果实际上正在导致我遭受痛苦，可能也导致了她遭受痛苦，因为想象一下，每次你和别人谈话时，你都必须与你生活中最艰难的部分搏斗，并且被要求去面对它、改变它，然而你又做不到。所以我们俩实际上都在承受更多的痛苦，
for for the rest of her life and her marriage continuing on happily ever after as idealistic as that was. And then there was also this violation of my efficacy as a good son who's going to help her and pull her out of things through my sheer ingenuity. I realized that I too was running along a script. The result of me running through the script of trying to play psychoanalyst, of pushing her to change, of pushing her to accept certain facts was actually causing me to suffer and probably also causing her to suffer because then every, imagine every time you talk to someone, you have to grapple with the hardest parts of your life and you're being asked to confront it and change and then you can't do it. So both of us are actually suffering more,
这不仅是她自己的期望或世界模型被违背的产物，也是我顽固地坚持自己能够介入并解决问题的模型的结果。意识到我在感觉像是我们关系恶化中也扮演了角色，这对我当时来说是一个非常重要的洞察，因为我开始确信我做事的方式带来的危害大于益处。就在那时，我认为这真正成了一个去思考践行我一直在宣扬的理念的机会。因此，如果我的母亲无法放下她的期望并更新她的世界模型来接受现实情况，也许我可以提升自我并接受现实
not just as a product of her own expectations or model of the world being violated, but of me stubbornly clinging to my model of being able to come in and fix things. And realizing that my model of being able to come in and fix things. And realizing that I had a part to play in what felt like the degradation of our relationship was a really important insight for me at the time because I was becoming convinced that the way I was going about things was doing more harm than good. And at that point, I think it really became an opportunity to think about practicing what I had been preaching. So if my mother is not able to let go of her expectations and update her model of the world to accept the reality of the situation, maybe I could work on myself and accept the reality
情况。修复她或拯救她不是我的工作，也不是我的能力所及。和她通电话并彻底停止整个过程会是怎样的体验，就像打破试图修复她的剧本一样？这是一种在当下与她共处更激进的方式，就像是：你今天可以是任何人，我今天就让你成为任何人。与她共处在当下，就像是：你今天可以是任何人，我今天就让你成为任何人。这意味着你今天可能会很好。所以打个电话，真正地只是倾听——她最近过得怎么样，既不奖赏那种反刍思维，也不买账那种指责的故事，但与此同时，不参与这种热心的刨根问底，而是更多地
of the situation. It wasn't my job or my ability to fix her or save her. What would it be like to have a phone conversation with her and just stop the whole process, like break the script of trying to fix her? It was a more radical way of being with her in the moment, which is like, you could be anyone today and I'm going to let you be anyone today. being with her in the moment, which is like, you could be anyone today and I'm going to let you be anyone today. And that means you might be fine today. So just call it and just really just listen like how is she doing and not reward the rumination or buy into the blame story, but at the same time, not engage in this kind of therapeutic delving and more
尝试去树立（你知道的）一种健康的互动可能会是什么样的榜样，也就是告诉她我爱她、我关心她，跟她聊聊我的近况，把注意力重新引导回我们正在进行的经历上。因为我意识到我的模型也是一个从“有些地方出了严重错误”的假设出发的模型。所以我们俩都是从事情出了问题这个假设开始的。那么，如果我放下这一点，模型会是什么样子的呢？如果当下她独自一人、情绪抑郁、有着这些反刍思维，而我感到怨恨，这些其实并没有什么不对呢？
try to model, you know, what a healthy interaction might be like, which is just telling her, I love her, I care for her, telling her a bit about my day, directing attention back just to our ongoing experience. Because what I realized is my model was also one that began from a place where there was something horribly wrong. And so we're both starting with this assumption where things are wrong. So what would a model look like where I let go of that? And what if there was nothing wrong in the moment with the fact that she was alone and depressed and having these ruminations and I was feeling resentment?
如果所有这一切都在发生，然后我们依然只是要进行一次愉快的谈话呢。随着时间的推移，我注意到的是——我不会说这是我经历过最有趣的谈话——但它们的厌恶感大大降低了。我们只会进行一些闲聊和小聚，传达出我们依然感到彼此连接、互相爱护。然后发生了一件完全意想不到的事情，那就是对话变短了。我觉得我可以更频繁地主动与她联系。因此，与那种“如果我能修复她，我就不必一直进行这些痛苦的对话”的整个叙事不同，我可以，我会说，你知道，今天是星期四，为什么我不直接打电话问候她一下呢？因为我知道现在大概只需要五到十分钟。
And what if all that was going on and then we're still just going to have a nice conversation. And over time, what I noticed was I wouldn't say like they were the funnest conversations I ever had, but they became much less aversive. We would just kind of have small talk and chat and communicate that we still felt connected and loved each other. And something totally unexpected happened, which was the conversations became shorter. And I felt like I could initiate contact with her more often. So as opposed to the whole narrative being like, if I can fix or I won't have to have these painful conversations all the time, I could just, I would say, you know, it's like Thursday, but why don't I just call and check in with her? Because I knew it would only be like five or 10 minutes now.
最后我们开始在大多数日子里都会通话，但方式要轻快得多，绝对没有那么多期待带来的负担。在某种程度上，这真的改变了我们关系的轨迹，直到那个时候，这段关系一直都在走下坡路。诺姆的母亲对她的人生结果仍然感到沮丧。她仍然停留在过去。诺姆很沮丧。他的母亲没有遵循他的心理学建议，这本可以使她的情况变得更好。
And we ended up starting to talk more days than not, but in a much sort of lighter, definitely less expectancy laden way. And in some ways that really shifted the trajectory of our relationship, which until that point had been heading downhill. Norm's mother was still upset with how her life had turned out. She was still stuck on the past. Norm was upset. His mother wasn't following his psychology advice, which could make things better for
但在未来。然而，当他们的对话聚焦于日常生活事件时，它自动淡化了过去和未来，并将他们聚焦于此时此地。他们的对话开始有了更多的变化。有些天他们谈论悲伤的事情，另一些天则谈论快乐或有趣的事情。因为她非常孤立，所以我们的社交互动确实对她一天的社交质量产生了巨大的影响。因此，如果这些互动
her in the future. But when their conversations focused on daily events, it automatically downplayed both the past and the future and focused them on the here and now. Their conversations started to have more variability. Some days they talked about sad things, other days about happy things or funny things. Because she was so isolated, like our social interactions really were contributing a huge amount of the interpersonal quality to her day. So, if those interactions
充满压力，她的一天就会充满压力。最终，事情会变成这样：你今天过得怎么样？回答会是：挺好的。我们没有用注意力去奖赏关于过去的故事，但我们也没有试图去阻止它。所以，我们只是开始一起继续我们的生活。是的，直到现在，虽然她还会有状态好和状态不好的日子，但我们仍然经常交谈，感觉就像正常人一样，这正是我拼命想要实现、而当我试图扮演治疗师时却讽刺地未能实现的目标。我们用来在生活中航行的地图是非常有用的。然而，有时它们会把我们引入歧途。当我们回来时，关于我们的大脑如何想出地图的奇妙脑科学，以及
were stressful, her day was going to be stressful. Eventually, it would just be like, how's your day? And it'd be like, it was fine. We weren't rewarding attention into the story about the past, but we weren't trying to prevent it. So, we just started to get on with our lives together. Yeah, to the point now where, yeah, she'll have good days and bad days, but we still talk quite frequently and it just feels like normal, which is something I was desperately trying to achieve and sort of ironically failing to do when I was trying to play therapist. The maps we use to navigate through life are enormously useful. Sometimes however, they can lead us astray. When we come back, the curious brain science of how our minds come up with maps, and what
当现实告诉我们这些地图是错的时会发生什么。您正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》。当现实告诉我们这些地图是错的时会发生什么。您正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹坦。这是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹坦。当我们穿梭于世界时，很容易想象我们正在处理周围发生的一切，然后决定如何应对。但事实证明，这样做将极其复杂且耗时。我们的大脑旨在节省能量，而不是浪费能量。在多伦多大学，心理学家和神经科学家
happens when reality tells us that those maps are wrong. You're listening to Hidden Brain. and what happens when reality tells us that those maps are wrong. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedant. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedanthan. As we move through the world, it's easy to imagine we are processing everything that happens around us and then deciding how to respond. But it turns out, this would be incredibly complex and time-consuming to do. Our brains are designed to save energy, not waste it. At the University of Toronto, psychologist and neuroscientist
诺曼·法布研究我们的大脑如何通过想出地图来高效地在世界上导航。所以，诺姆，假设我每天上下班通勤。我开车或乘坐公共交通工具。我这样做的第一天，它是新鲜的。第三天，它变得熟悉了。到了第十天，它就成了一种惯例。在概念层面上，你能谈谈当我的通勤从陌生和新奇变得熟悉和寻常时，我的脑海中发生了什么吗？当然。我们的大脑进化要做的主要事情之一，就是把我们现实中的任何模式拿来并使该过程自动化。所以，是的，第一次开车时，你要处理的问题是，好吧，我
Norman Farb studies how our brains efficiently navigate the world by coming up with maps. So, Norm, let's say I'm commuting to work every day. I drive or I take public transport. The first day I do this, it's novel. The third day, it becomes familiar. By the tenth day, it's a routine. At a conceptual level, can you talk about what happens in my mind as my commute goes from being new and strange to familiar and commonplace? Sure. One of the main things that our brains have evolved to do, which is to take any sort of pattern in our reality and automate that process. So yeah, that first time you're driving, the problem you're trying to deal with is, okay, I'm
要去一个新地方，我在哪里转弯，交通状况如何？但一旦路线变得熟悉，你就会想，哦，对了，当我看到那边那丛绿灌木时，就该减速并右转了。不知不觉中，你甚至不用思考就能完成它。当然，这一切并不仅限于物理导航。你在公司上班的第一天和你上班的第264天完全不同。所以我们的地图不仅关乎物理地形，还关乎我们的行为。是的，大脑正试图建立一个世界的模型，让它能够预测接下来会发生什么，这个想法适用于生活的方方面面，从弄清楚如何与一个在工作中有时有点棘手的人说话，到最抽象的事情，甚至是关于我们应该思考什么，我们应该关心的什么，什么值得倾注我们的情感精力和注意力。随着时间的推移，所有这些决定都变得自动化了，这样任何剩余的资源都可以用来处理意料之外的事情。诺姆和其他研究人员已经确定了大脑中参与这一过程的网络。它被称为默认模式网络。冒着过度简化的风险，
going somewhere new, where do I have to turn, what's traffic like? But once the route becomes familiar and you're like, oh yeah, when I see the the green bush over there, it's getting time to slow down and turn right. Before you know it, you're doing it without even thinking. And of course, this is all not limited just to physical navigation. Your first day at work is nothing like your 264th day at work. So our maps are not just about physical terrain, they're about what we do. Yeah, the idea that the brain is trying to set up a model of the world that lets it predict what's going to happen next applies to all facets of life from figuring out how to speak to someone who's a bit prickly at work to the most abstract
默认模式网络就是大脑在问自己：我能把刚刚发生的事情纳入一个模式、一个世界模型中吗？是的，所以默认模式网络是一组大脑区域，当我们没有什么特别的事情要做时，当我们接到指令去休息并只做对我们来说自然而然的事情时，这些区域似乎是最活跃的。所以这也是“默认”这个词的来源。这是默认情况下发生在我们身上的事情。所以我们感觉到默认模式网络正在我们的大脑中实例化一个习惯，这样随着事情变得熟悉，我们的预测大体上可以覆盖我们接下来需要做的事情，并且我们不需要进行大量的有意识处理，
things even of what should we think about, what should we care about, what is worth devoting our emotional energy and attention. All of these decisions become automated over time so that any leftover resources can be used to deal with the unexpected. Norm and other researchers have identified a network in the brain that is involved in this process. It's called the default mode network. At the risk of oversimplifying things,
这就是大脑网络，它变得最活跃是为了处理来自世界的预期输入和输出。因此，默认模式网络给我们带来麻烦的一种方式是，当我们开始觉得我们对世界的地图实际上就是世界时。你能谈谈那个吗？在某种程度上，我们在做事，我们在重复做事。一段时间后，在某些情况下，我们构建了一个关于这个东西是什么的模型，因为我们不需要
the default mode network is the brain asking itself, can I take what just happened and fit it into a pattern, a model of the world? Yeah, so the default mode network is a constellation of brain regions that seem to be most active when we're not up to anything in particular, when we're given instructions to rest and just do whatever comes natural for us. So this is part of the term default. It's what happens to us by default. So we have the sense that the default mode network is instantiating a habit in our brain so that as things become familiar and our predictions can mostly just cover what we need to do next, and we don't have to do a lot of conscious processing,
每次都费力地去做。但一段时间后，模型开始替代世界本身，替代我们正在做的事情本身。你能谈谈这个过程是如何发生的吗，也就是在某种程度上，你正在训练飞机上的自动驾驶功能，可以这么说，但一段时间后，自动驾驶仪只是简单地开始驾驶飞机，而我们忘记了实际上还有一个可以驾驶飞机的飞行员。是的。
this is the brain network that becomes most active to deal with the expected input, output from the world. So one way that the default mode network can get us in trouble is when we start to feel like our map of the world actually is the world. Can you talk about that for a moment? That in some ways we're doing things, we're doing things repetitively. After some time, in some ways, we build a model of what this thing is because we don't
我的意思是，我认为我们会有这样的时刻。我们只是走进一个房间，开始做某事，然后意识到这不是我们原本打算做的。所以我们隐约感觉到有时自动驾驶仪会在行为层面上接管。但我认为我们经常没有意识到的是，我们的习惯不仅是行为习惯，也是感官习惯。所以当我走进一个房间时，我应该看哪里？我应该注意谁？我应该想些什么样的事情？我应该考虑什么样的计划？推而广之，我们还在过滤掉许多许多其他的可能性。因此，默认模式网络不仅在习惯方面进行观察，比如
have to do it effortfully each time. But after some time, the model comes to substitute for the world itself, for the thing that we're doing itself. Can you talk about how that process happens, which is in some ways, you're training the autopilot function on the plane, so to say, but after some time, the autopilot just simply starts flying the plane and we forget that actually there is a pilot available to fly the plane as well. Yeah.
我是否锻炼，或者我多久洗一次澡，它还观察我们与现实的哪些部分互动的非常基本的习惯。这些是我们建立了最深层模型的东西。我们一遍又一遍地练习这样做。如果我们总是右转，我们在上班的路上就不会考虑左转。我们不会想知道左边发生了什么，因为这无关紧要。我们已经了解到这无关紧要。在社交层面上，我们已经了解到某些话题是无关紧要的。它们对我们来说没有那么重要。有些人是无关紧要的，或者对我们来说没有那么重要。甚至当我们与我们认识并有一定联系的人交谈时，也有某些事情是我们习惯与他们讨论的，而另一些事情
I mean, I think we have moments of this. We'll just sort of walk into a room and start doing something and then realize it's not what we intended to do. So we have glimpses that sometimes the autopilot takes over at a behavioral level. But I think what we don't often realize is that our habits are not just habits of behavior, they're also habits of perception. So where should I look when I walk into a room? Who should I pay attention to? What sorts of things should I think about? What sorts of plans should I consider? And by extension, we're also filtering out many, many other possibilities. So the default mode network is not just looking at habits in terms
他们根本不是那种我会与之分享的人，或者我不会让谈话朝那个方向发展。这一切都源于我们如何感知周围的世界，并在这种情况下过滤掉什么重要、什么不重要。默认模式网络也在这样做。所以从某种程度上说，这极大地简化了“我在每个给定的时刻都在做什么”的问题。但它也通过对此时此刻还有哪些其他可能性制造出巨大的盲点来简化事情，这对我们改变的能力有着重大的影响。我想到了你给我讲的关于你妈妈的故事。她不时地认识到，
of, you know, do I exercise or not, or how often do I bathe, but also really fundamental habits for what parts of our reality we interact with. And these are the things that we have most deeply modeled. We practice doing it over and over again. We don't consider turning left on our way to work if we always turn right. We don't wonder what is going on to the left of us because it's irrelevant. We've learned that it's irrelevant. And at a social level, we've learned that some topics are irrelevant. They're not that important to us. Some people are irrelevant or not that important to us. And even when we're talking to someone we know and have some affiliation with, there are certain things we're used to discussing with them and other things that
对我来说，最好不要沉湎于过去，对前夫也不要有那么多敌意。我应该继续我的生活。你在脑海中的某个层面了解这些事情，但在某种程度上，你的默认状态是弹回到这个模型中，该模型说：这就是承诺给我的世界，而世界并非如此发展。
they're just not the kind of person I would share that with or I wouldn't make the conversation go in that way. And that all comes from just how we perceive the world around us and filter what matters and what doesn't matter in that context. And the default mode network is doing that too. So in a way, this greatly simplifies the problem of like, what am I doing in every given moment? But it also, the way it simplifies things is by creating massive blind spots as to what are all the other things that are possible in this moment, which has big implications for our ability to change. I'm thinking about the story you told me about your mom. She recognizes from time to time,
而我的大脑不断回到那种感到被背叛和失望的死胡同里。是的，就像一个凹槽，对吧，或者一个通道，我们的思维更容易顺着那个方向流动，我认为这是一个很好的隐喻。我们知道我们有一些想要改变的心理习惯。因此，在我们集中精力的时候，我们利用注意力来做出不同的选择。我们有这种能动性，但我们的注意力是非常脆弱的东西。一旦我们不再关注，我们就会分心，特别是如果我们感到压力并全神贯注于别的事情时，那么填满后台所有内容的
it might be better for me not to dwell on the past and not to have so much animosity towards my ex-husband. I should move forward with my life. You sort of know these things at one level in your mind, but at some level, your default is to spring back into this model that says, here's the world that I was promised and the world didn't turn out that way.
该做什么、想什么、回忆什么的，就是默认模式网络。所以我知道我不应该去想这个消极的事件，因为我会心烦意乱。仅仅是“这在目前其实并不明智”这种短暂的指令，与所有这些说“你应该多想想它，这关乎你”的机制相比，几乎没有什么力量。我们从其他研究中知道，思考自我比任何其他类型的思考都享有最高优先级，因为这些类型的思考根据定义与我们的生存息息相关。我的意思是，我猜如果你开车在一条街上，现在我们看到红灯，我们大多数人不会
And my mind keeps returning to that groove of feeling betrayed and let down. Yeah, the idea of like a groove, right, or a channel that it's just easier for our thoughts to flow that way I think is a really good metaphor. We know that we have certain mental habits that we would like to change. So at the times that we're effortfully concentrating, we're using our attention to choose differently. We have this sense of agency, but our attention is a very fragile thing. And as soon as we're no longer paying attention, we become distracted or especially if we're stressed and fixated on something else, then what's filling in all the background of what
经历费力的过程，说：好吧，那是我前面的交通信号灯，灯变红了。红色意味着我应该减速并停下来，所以我应该停下来，因为那是红灯。所有这一切都是自动发生的，而你真正要说的是，同样的事情也发生在人际关系层面上，例如。我们有这些默认值，当我们看到人时，我们与他们有过某些对话模式，而默认模式网络在某种程度上把我们置于与我们看到红灯时相同的模式中，我们会自动停下来。对，并不是说
to do, what to think about, what to recall is the default mode network. So I know I shouldn't think about this negative event because I'll become upset. And just the momentary instruction of like, well, this actually isn't skillful right now has very little power compared to all of this machinery saying you should think about it more, it's about you. And we know from other research that thinking about the self gets the highest priority over any kind of other thinking because those are the types of thoughts that are by definition relevant for our survival. I mean I'm imagining that if you're driving on a street for example and now we see a red light, most of us are not
对红灯完全没有意识到，更像是让我们抄近路跳过所有的推理，只给你一种基本的感觉，即你现在需要这样做。而且如果不这样做可能会很危险或令人不快。这就是默认模式网络试图为我们简化事情的方式。这伴随着权衡，因为这个网络几乎就像我们心中的一种确定感，但世界本身是一个不稳定和不断变化的地方，所以如果我们现在学到的东西被过度泛化，或者即使是像同一个人，但假设那个人已经改变了，或者情况已经改变了，我们就会很难改变这种编程。我的意思是，正如你所指出的，当你和你的妈妈交谈时，从某种程度上开始
going through the effortful process of saying, all right, that's a traffic signal in front of me, the light is turned red. Red is supposed to mean that I'm supposed to slow down and stop, so I should come to a stop because it's a red light. All of that is happening automatically, and really what you're saying is that the same thing happens at the level of interpersonal relationships, for example. We have these defaults where we see people, we've had certain patterns of conversations with them, and the default mode network in some ways is putting us into the same mode that we are in when we see a red light and we automatically come to a stop. Right, and it's not that
使用这样的默认设置更容易：你知道，她有麻烦了，她很沮丧，我需要帮助她，她需要治疗，而不是说，让我们看看她今天在哪里。让我们关注今天实际发生的事情。这是一个更加费力的过程，需要真正去解读事情的发展方向，而不是假设你知道它们在哪里。是的。因此，带着“对一个人一无所知”的假设进去，并对这种信息洪流保持开放，不知道该注意什么，不知道这个人是谁，这要费力得多。每次都从头开始是一个极其费力且也有点可怕的过程，
there's zero awareness on a red light, it's more like let's shortcut through all the reasoning and just give you sort of a basic feeling of like you need to do this now. And it might be dangerous or unpleasant not to. And this is the default mode network trying to simplify things for us. That comes with trade-offs because this network is almost like a feeling of certainty in our minds, but the world itself is an unstable and changing place, so it can make it very difficult for us to change
对吧？了解人们是谁、他们在忙什么、他们可能会对你说什么或做什么会带来一种安全感。而容许任何事情都有可能发生的可能性会让你变得脆弱，对吧？如果这意味着你必须做出不同的反应呢？让某人完全以不同的方式出现，这几乎可能带有一种恐惧感，
if that learning is now being overgeneralized, or even if it's like the same person, but let's say that person has changed, or the situation has changed, it's gonna be hard for us to change that programming. I mean, as you pointed out, when you were talking to your mom, it was easier in some ways to start
因为我们想要假设我们明天会是同一个人，而且其他人会保持一致。如果他们不是呢？所以你对经历过或正在经历抑郁症的人进行了一系列神经成像研究，你把他们放在实验室里的fMRI扫描仪中，这样你就可以看到他们大脑中发生了什么。在一项研究中，你把人们放在这个大脑扫描仪中，让他们观看非常悲伤的电影片段。
with the default of saying, you know, she is in trouble, she is depressed, I need to help her, she's in need of therapy, as opposed to say, let's see where she is today. Let's pay attention to what's actually going on today. That's a much more effortful process of actually reading where things are, rather than assuming you know where they are. Yeah. So it's much more effortful to go in, assuming you know nothing about a person and be open to this flood of information and not knowing what to pay attention to and not knowing who this person is. And starting from beginning each time is a hugely effortful and also kind of scary process,
这些片段是什么？你发现了什么，诺姆？是的，所以为了成为一台好的预测机器，大脑的诀窍是将你瞬间体验中发生的任何事情与过去的其它事件联系起来，以便你可以对这些事件进行语境化和解释。这就是为什么我们认为当人们暴露于悲伤中时，我们会看到默认模式网络被激活、在扫描仪中亮起的原因，因为他们看到事情正在发生。我们展示了失落的痛苦主题，你知道，我们展示了《母女情深》的片段，母亲因为患有晚期癌症而不得不与孩子告别，例如。而大脑似乎在说：哦，好吧，我看到了这种人际互动正在发生。这里发生了什么？
right? There's a safety in knowing who people are and what they're up to and what they might say or do to you. And to entertain the possibility that anything could happen kind of makes you vulnerable, right? And what if that means you could have to respond in different ways, right? There might almost be a fearfulness in letting someone just show up totally differently
哦，一位母亲生病了，她不得不与孩子们告别。我们立即将这与我们自己经历过的失落、不得不与亲人告别、生命的脆弱、我们自己破裂的关系联系起来。这帮助我们从仅仅看到像素在屏幕上移动，转变为真正感觉沉浸在故事中。这就是为什么我们如此喜欢故事，因为它们不仅关乎故事中的主角，它们关乎我们。这就是默认模式。现在我们有点在填补空白，哇，看这个特定的刺激、这个特定的事件或经历是多么丰富地成为了许多其他经历的候选者，或者是我们自己生活中发生过的许多其他经历的原型。这是一种无处不在的反应，试图
because we wanna assume that we're gonna be the same person tomorrow and that other people are gonna be consistent. What if they're not? So you've conducted a number of neuroimaging studies of people who have experienced or are currently experiencing depression, you put them in the fMRI scanner in your lab so you can see what's going on in their brains. In one study, you put people in this brain scanner and you asked them to watch very sad film clips.
思考，你知道，我如何根据我已经了解的关于我自己和世界的知识来理解这种体验。现在，你确实发现了一个区别：倾向于抑郁的人和没有表现出抑郁迹象的人之间存在差异，但它不在默认模式网络中，而是在大脑的另一个区域。你发现了什么，诺姆？是的，这真的让我们感到惊讶，默认模式网络并没有驱动我们对谁抑郁、谁不抑郁的预测。
What were these clips and what did you find, Norm? Yeah, so in order to be a good prediction machine, the name of the game for the brain is to associate whatever is happening in your momentary experience with other past events so that you can contextualize and interpret those events. And this is why we think we see the default mode network activating, lighting up in the scanner when people are exposed to sadness is they see something happening. We show sign themes of loss, you know, we show clips from Terms of Endearment and the mother saying goodbye to her kids because she has terminal cancer for instance. And the brain is sort of saying, oh, okay, I'm getting this interpersonal interaction happening. What's happening here?
我们曾认为，当然，抑郁的人如此沉溺于他们消极的生活故事中，以至于这导致了抑郁，但事实并非如此。我不得不开启我自己的期望集，即我对将要发生的事情的地图，并说：好吧，如果我要从这项研究中得出一些关于抑郁症的信息，也许我应该寻找大脑中正在发生其他什么事情。当我开始寻找大脑中哪些部分在失活时——我们在其中实际看到在观看悲伤电影时与中性电影相比活动减少了——我们看到，正是大脑中代表身体内部发生的事情的那部分倾向于关闭。
Oh, a mother is sick and she's having to say goodbye to her kids. And we immediately relate that to our own experiences of loss, of having to say goodbye to loved ones, of the fragility of life, you know, our own severed relationships. And this helps us go from just seeing like pixels moving around on a screen to really feeling like immersed in a story. This is why we enjoy stories so much because they aren't just about the protagonist in the story, they're about us. And that's the default mode. Now we're kind of filling in like, wow, like look at how richly this particular stimulus, this particular event or experience is actually a candidate for many other experiences or a prototype of many other experiences that have happened in our own lives. It's a ubiquitous kind of response to try to
我们知道大脑中有几乎每个人都有的部分，代表着你身体表面发生的事情。我们知道大脑中有代表身体内部感觉状态的部分。正是这些区域在对悲伤电影片段的反应中失活。真正让我确信这里面有一个故事的是——因为我认为即使是一般科学界也不会这样看待抑郁症和脆弱性，它仍然被认为是威胁信号的触发，然后触发你进入防御习惯——真正让我确信这一点很重要的是，当我们观察大脑的哪些部分具有与以下情况相关或帮助我们预测某人是否活动的区域时
think about, you know, how can I make sense of this experience in terms of what I already know about myself and the world. Now you did find a difference between people who are prone to depression and people who are not showing signs of depression, but it wasn't in the default mode network, but in another region of the brain. What did you find, Noor? Yeah, so this really surprised us that the default mode network wasn't driving our prediction of who is depressed and who wasn't.
思考一下，你知道的，我如何根据我已知关于自己和世界的知识来理解这段经历。现在，你确实发现倾向于抑郁的人和没有表现出抑郁迹象的人之间存在差异，但这不在默认模式网络中，而是在大脑的另一个区域。你发现了什么，努尔？是的，这让我们非常惊讶，默认模式网络并没有驱动我们对谁抑郁、谁不抑郁的预测。
We thought, of course, people who are depressed are so sucked into their negative life stories that this is causing depression, and it just wasn't. I had to sort of open up my own set of expectations, my map for what was going to happen and say, okay, well, if I'm going to make something out of this study that tells us something about depression, maybe I should look for what else is happening in the brain. And when I started now looking at what parts of the brain were deactivating, where we actually saw less activity during sad films compared to neutral films, we saw that it was the parts of our brain that represent what's happening in our bodies that tend to be turning off.
我们原以为，抑郁的人肯定深陷于他们的负面生活故事中，这导致了抑郁，但事实并非如此。我不得不稍微敞开心扉，调整我自己的期望集、我对将要发生的事情的蓝图，然后说，好吧，如果我要从这项研究中得出一些关于抑郁的事情，也许我应该寻找大脑中正在发生的其他事情。当我开始寻找大脑哪些部分在失活时——我们在观看悲伤电影时实际看到的活动比中性电影少——我们发现，往往是那些代表我们身体内部正在发生的事情的大脑区域在关闭。
There's parts of the brain that we know across almost every person represents what's happening on the surface of your body. We know that there's parts of the brain that represent the internal feeling state of the body. And it was these regions that were deactivating in response to the sad film clips. And what really convinced me that there was a story here, because this is not how I think even the general scientific community would think of depression, vulnerability, it's still thought of as being the triggering of threat signals that then trigger you into your defensive habits. So what really convinced me that this was important was when we looked at what parts of the brain had activity that correlated with or helped us predict whether someone
我们知道，几乎在每个人身上，都有一些大脑区域代表着你身体表面正在发生的事情。我们知道，有一些大脑区域代表着身体的内部感觉状态。正是这些区域在对悲伤电影片段的反应中处于失活状态。真正让我相信这里面有一个故事的是——因为我认为即使是普通科学界也不会这样看待抑郁和脆弱性，它仍然被认为会触发威胁信号，进而触发你的防卫习惯。所以真正让我相信这一点很重要的是，当我们观察大脑的哪些部分具有与以下情况相关或帮助我们预测某人的活动时
was depressed or not, it was this pattern of deactivation in body representation regions that was significantly associated with whether people were depressed or not. And it did not seem diagnostic to look at differences in how much people were activating the default mode network. It just seemed that what might be pathological or harmful is doing this to the exclusion of continuing to process and update yourself with information about how your body is feeling. And when you say how the body is feeling, you mean everything from, you know, are my eyes seeing color? Are my ears hearing
是否抑郁，身体表征区域的这种去激活模式与人们是否抑郁显著相关。而且，观察人们激活默认模式网络的程度差异似乎并无诊断意义。似乎病态或有害的做法是，一面这样做，一面却不再继续处理和更新关于你身体感觉的信息。当你提到身体感觉时，你的意思是各种感受，比如，你知道的，我的眼睛能看到颜色吗？我的耳朵能听到
sound? What is the feeling of the carpet on my feet or the desk under my arm? It's all of the carpet on my feet or the desk under my arm. It's all of the feelings and sensations that are flooding into the brain. You're saying that in people who had a propensity for depression, these areas were suppressed. These signals were being suppressed. Right, the most pronounced places that were associated with depression were specifically the regions for,
声音吗？脚下的地毯或胳膊下的桌子是什么感觉？所有这些涌入大脑的感觉和知觉。你是说，在有抑郁倾向的人身上，这些区域被抑制了？这些信号被抑制了？对，与抑郁最相关的最显著部位正是那些负责以下功能的区域：
what am I feeling in my body right now? So as you know, how do I feel lying here in the scanner? Am I hot or cold right now? Do I feel sensations like in my gut? Does my heart ache? My throat feel constricted? And if we think about our strong emotional responses, you feel it a lot of times in your chest and in your gut. And if this signal is being suppressed while you're thinking about your sadness, it's that kind of perfect storm that's actually associated with depression, which pose its own sort of conceptual mysteries for us to understand because it's not at all what we expected. It's almost at that point like you have a brain without a body. Your brain is
我现在身体有什么感觉？比如，你知道的，我躺在扫描仪里感觉如何？我现在感觉冷还是热？我能感觉到胃里的感觉吗？我的心脏在痛吗？我的喉咙感到紧缩吗？如果我们想想我们强烈的负面情绪反应，你很多时候能在胸口和胃里感受到它。如果当你想着自己的悲伤时，这个信号却被抑制了，这就造成了一种完美的风暴，实际上与抑郁有关，这给我们理解带来了一些概念上的谜题，因为这完全出乎我们的意料。那种感觉几乎就像你拥有一个没有身体的大脑。你的大脑
full of its own thoughts, its own activity, its own self-perception, but it's not paying attention to signals coming in from the body. That's right. In the case of depression vulnerability, what's happening is people are saying, well, I want to protect myself from these negative feelings. They feel bad or threatening and they're just icky. And so I'm going to just for now, I'm going to pause taking a new information just while my brain thinks about this model of me being sad. And meanwhile, the default mode network is saying, I'm just going to keep thinking about all the reasons I should feel sad right now and I've felt sad in the past and link all this information together until I get interrupted by new information. So, you have this kind of
充满了它自己的想法、它自己的活动、它自己的自我感知，但它却不关注来自身体的信号。确实如此。在抑郁易感性的情况下，发生的情况是人们在说，嗯，我要保护自己免受这些负面情绪的影响。它们感觉不好或具有威胁性，而且让人很不舒服。所以目前我打算这样做，我要暂停接收新信息，就当我脑子里在思考这个关于我正在悲伤的模型时。与此同时，默认模式网络却在说，我只想继续思考所有我此刻应该感到悲伤、过去也感到悲伤的理由，并将所有这些信息联系在一起，直到我被新信息打断。所以，这就形成了一种
recipe for turning on the sadness machine and then locking all the doors for other visitors that might interrupt sadness. So, there's this ironic perpetuation of our sadness by conceptualizing it and cutting out the sensory aspects of it. The default mode network is not in the business of changing unless it has to integrate new information and now we're not letting it integrate new information. ["Skyfall"]
开启悲伤机器然后锁死所有可能打断悲伤的其他访客的大门的方法。因此，通过概念化悲伤并切断其感官层面，我们对悲伤进行了讽刺般的延续。默认模式网络若非必须整合新信息，是不会轻易改变的，而现在我们却不让它整合新信息。["Skyfall"]
To put this another way, the brain is doing two things. It's taking in information and then using that information to improve its internal maps of the world. People with a propensity for depression seem to stop taking in information, leaving the brain with only its own internal maps. If those maps are filled with ruminations about an unfair, unkind, unhappy world, that becomes the only world we can see. Even if good things happen to us, even when we catch a break, our internal map continues to paint a picture of gloom.
换句话说，大脑在做两件事。它接收信息，然后利用这些信息来完善其关于世界的内部地图。有抑郁倾向的人似乎停止了接收信息，这使得大脑只剩下它自己的内部地图。如果这些地图充满了对一个不公平、不友好、不快乐的世界的反复咀嚼，那这就成了我们能看到的唯一世界。即使好事降临在我们身上，即使我们得到了转机，我们的内部地图依然在描绘一幅阴暗的画面。
When we come back, how to update our internal maps? You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. Norman Farb is a psychologist and neuroscientist at the University of Toronto. With Zindel Siegel, he's the author of Better in Every Sense, How the New Science of Sensation Can Help You Reclaim Your Life. Pop psychology talks a lot about the differences between the left brain and the right brain. But Norm says the more important distinction might be between the front of the brain and
回来后，我们将讨论如何更新我们的内部地图。欢迎收听《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。诺曼·法布是多伦多大学的心理学家和神经科学家。他和齐德尔·西格尔合著了《全方位变好：感官的新科学如何帮您重塑生活》。大众心理学经常谈论左脑和右脑的区别。但诺姆表示，更重要的区别可能在于大脑的前部和
the back of the brain. The front of the brain is where a lot of our mapmaking happens. The back of the brain is mostly where the brain picks up information from our senses. Among people with a propensity for depression, Norm says the mapmaking part of the brain is very active, while the part that processes sensory information is shut down. The more stressed we become, the more we start seeing that the front of the brain becomes active and many parts of the back of our brain are becoming deactivated. So I think you can think of it as a tale of two partners that are trying to work together to help get you through life.
大脑的后部。大脑前部是我们进行大量地图绘制的地方。大脑后部则主要是大脑接收感官信息的地方。诺姆说，在有抑郁倾向的人中，大脑负责绘制地图的部分非常活跃，而处理感官信息的部门却关闭了。我们感到压力越大，就会发现大脑前部变得越活跃，而大脑后部的许多部分则被去激活了。所以我想你可以把它想象成两个试图合作帮你度过难关的伙伴的故事。
And one of these partners is Default Mode Network. It really uses a lot of the mental machinery that makes us more kind of evolved thinking beings in the front of the mental machinery that makes us more evolved thinking beings in the front of the brain. And its job is to make a really good model of the world and help us use that model to efficiently get through life. But this other partner is the sensory parts of our brain that are still open to the fact that the world is changing.
其中一个伙伴是默认模式网络。它确实大量利用了位于大脑前部的、使我们成为更具进化思维的生物的心理机制。它的工作是构建一个真正优秀的世界模型，并帮助我们利用该模型高效地度过生活。但另一个伙伴是我们大脑中仍然对世界正在改变这一事实保持开放态度的感官部分。
It's almost like this force of chaos. And we need to have chaos because the world is changing, right? It's almost like this force of chaos. And we need to have chaos because the world is changing and our models are going invariably to be wrong if they do not adapt to change. And so what seems to be happening when people become stressed or you feel like you're stuck in a rut or you wonder why you keep doing the same things or having the same interactions play out the same way, it seems to be the case that the part of our brain which we think is driven by default mode network activity has become too dominant. And it's happening at the expense of the sometimes scary process of letting the chaos of the
这几乎就像是一种混乱的力量。我们需要混乱，因为世界在改变，对吧？这几乎就像是一种混乱的力量。我们需要混乱，因为世界在改变，如果不去适应变化，我们的模型注定是错误的。所以，当人们感到压力，或者觉得陷入了死胡同，或者纳闷为什么自己总是在做同样的事情、或者以同样的方式进行同样的互动时，似乎发生的情况是：我们大脑中由默认模式网络活动驱动的那部分变得过于主导了。而这是以牺牲有时令人恐惧的过程为代价的，也就是让世界的
world in that could change our models of the world, which also means changing us. At the same time, I think this might explain now why someone who has a certain map of the world sort of finds themselves not able to extricate themselves from it. Part of the problem might be that they simply have stopped taking in information that could tell them that their map is wrong. Right. So if your response to a stressor is to think, okay, I don't have a lot of time to learn something new right now. I have to deal with this situation. What do I already have in my toolbox to deal with this sort of situation? Someone is being aggressive
混乱进入内部，这可能会改变我们对世界的模型，这也意味着改变我们自己。与此同时，我认为这或许可以解释为什么某个拥有特定世界模型的人会发现自己无法摆脱它。部分原因可能在于，他们干脆停止接收那些本可以告诉他们其地图是错误的信息。没错。所以，如果应对压力源的反应是认为，好吧，我现在没有太多时间去学习新东西。我必须处理这种情况。我的工具箱里有什么现成的工具来应对这种状况？有人在向我
towards me or I've just experienced a failure and I'm worried about what the future holds. We're driven to use what we already know. But if the problem is that what we already know is leading us to repeatedly get into conflict or to run into failure or to descend into the pits of despair, then we just keep reaching into the toolbox that is the same tools that are causing the problem in the first place. Hmm. I'm also imagining, let's say you have a fight with someone who is close to you and the fight is very
表现出攻击性，或者我刚刚经历了一场失败，我担心未来会怎样。我们被驱使着去使用我们已知的东西。但如果问题在于，我们已知的东西正导致我们陷入一而再再而三的冲突、遭遇失败、或者坠入绝望的深渊，那么我们就会不断地去工具箱里拿那些最初正是导致问题的相同工具。唔。我还在想，假设你和你亲近的人大吵了一架，这场争吵非常
painful and you're flooded with all kinds of sensations, your cortisol levels are elevated. So there's a lot of signals coming in from your body that in fact something very unpleasant has happened and now your default mode network kicks in. You're telling yourself a story about how this fight came to be and what your relationship is like with this other person. You have now the elaboration of the map. You have a map of the fight in addition to the fight. I think what you're saying is that two hours after the fight is over, the body has stopped sending you signals that a terrible fight has happened.
痛苦，你被各种各样的感觉淹没，你的皮质醇水平升高了。所以你的身体传来了很多信号，表明确实发生了非常不愉快的事情，现在你的默认模式网络开始发挥作用了。你在给自己讲一个关于这场争吵是如何发生的、以及你和另一个人关系如何的故事。现在你对地图进行了细化。除了争吵本身，你还有了一张关于争吵的地图。我想你的意思是，在争吵结束两个小时后，身体已经停止向你发送发生了可怕争吵的信号。
The body has gone back to baseline, but the story of the fight, the map of the fight, continues in our heads. And for some people, that map becomes so powerful that the fight now persists, and now it has a life that basically is lasting a week, a year, a decade, when the bodily sensations of that fight, in fact, have dissipated in a couple of hours. That's exactly right.
身体已经回到了基准线，但关于争吵的故事、争吵的地图，却依然在我们的脑海中延续。对某些人来说，那张地图变得如此强大，以至于争吵现在仍在持续，并且它的生命力基本上可以维持一周、一年、十年，而事实上，那场争吵的身体感觉在几个小时内就已经消散了。完全正确。
And then the insidious thing is that because you're telling this story, even after the body's calmed down, your body doesn't know the difference between you telling the story about the fight or the fight. So it thinks the fight's happening again. So you do actually get more cortisol and more stress hormones released into the body as you hold on to this over and over again. And so yeah, it's really just like this irony that it makes sense that we want to get away from feeling bad. We want to move things into a kind of conceptual realm where we can manipulate them and think about it in terms of a story and it's less energy intensive and all these things. So, it makes sense that we do this. But then before we know it, exactly as
然后，阴险的事情就在于，因为你在讲述这个故事，甚至在身体平静下来之后，你的身体也无法分辨你是在讲述关于争吵的故事还是争吵本身。所以它以为争吵又发生了。因此，当你一次又一次地抓住这一点不放时，你的身体确实会释放出更多的皮质醇和更多的应激激素。所以，是的，这真的就像是一种讽刺，我们想要远离糟糕的感觉，这在情理之中。我们希望将事情转移到概念领域，在那里我们可以操纵它们，用故事的形式去思考它们，而且这消耗的能量更少，诸如此类。所以，我们这样做是有道理的。但随后在我们意识到之前，正如
you said, now we have this model of the fight that we can carry with us wherever we go. And that's what happens in real life. Someone says something at work and then your body kind of calms down, but then driving home, you think about it again and the body reacts. And then you go home and you tell your loved one about it and so now it's happened again. And then you call your friend and you say, do you know what this person said to me and it happens again and again and again. So we are like inflicting the fight friend and you say, do you know what this person said to me? And it happens again and again and again.
你所说的那样，现在我们有了这个争吵的模型，无论走到哪里都可以随身携带。这就是现实生活中发生的事情。有人在工作时说了一句话，然后你的身体平静了下来，但在开车回家的路上，你又想起了这件事，身体又有了反应。然后你回到家，把这事告诉了你爱的人，于是事情又发生了一遍。接着你打电话给朋友，说你知道这人对我说什么了吗，然后事情又一遍一遍地发生。所以我们就像是在一遍又一遍地施加这场争吵，朋友，然后你说，你知道这人对我说什么了吗？事情又一遍又一遍地发生。
So we are like inflicting the fight over and over again, even though it was only like two or three minutes of our day. You know, I'm thinking about this story that is ascribed to Buddha and Buddhism. There's a story of something that's called a second arrow. And the Buddha is supposed to have said, as we go through life, you know,
所以我们就像是在一遍又一遍地施加这场争吵，尽管它在我们的一天中只持续了两三分钟。你知道，我正在想起这个归功于佛陀和佛教的故事。有一个关于所谓“第二支箭”的故事。据说佛陀曾说过，在我们经历生活的过程中，你知道的，
we're going to be struck with arrows. Unfortunate things are going to happen to us. Tragedies are going to strike us. But what we shouldn't do is we shouldn't take a second arrow and plunge it into the site of the first injury. And really what you've just described, you know, you have the fight at work, but then you're reliving that fight now 20 times.
我们会中箭。不幸的事情会降临在我们身上。悲剧会袭击我们。但我们不应该做的是，我们不应该再拿起第二支箭，刺入第一次受伤的部位。实际上，你刚才所描述的，你知道的，你在工作时吵了一架，但接下来你把那场争吵重温了20次。
And each of those 20 times, you're plunging a new arrow into the site of the old wound. I think there's a really nice parallel there. It's these stories we tell ourselves about the negative events that are like the second arrows potentially, if the stories we tell are negative or disempowering. And of course we learn what stories to tell
在这20次的每一次中，你都在往旧伤口上插一支新箭。我认为这里有一个非常美妙的平行关系。这些我们关于负面事件讲述的故事，如果讲述的故事是负面的或剥夺力量的，就可能像是第二支箭。当然，我们很早就通过周围人的行为模式，
to interpret events very early on in life through the modeling of the people around us. Norm says that being disconnected from our senses can keep us from feeling connected to other people. The more we live inside the world of our internal maps, and the less we pay attention to how our interactions with others make us feel, the less happy we are going to be. And it's kind of catastrophic because we know that
学会了如何讲述故事来解释事件。诺姆说，与感官断开连接会让我们无法感受到与他人的连接。我们越是活在内部地图的世界里，越是不去关注我们与他人的互动给我们带来了什么感觉，我们就会越不快乐。这简直是一场灾难，因为我们知道
our reasoning is never able to take everything into account. And there's times we can have, you know, perfect reasons for our actions and be doing drastic harm to our sense of relatedness or connectedness. We're not taught to balance this sort of reasoning with, well, what does it feel like while you're being right? You know, what does it feel like while you're showing that your model is the correct model? And I guess there's a trying to saying the signal that things need to change is often a sensory signal. It's this feeling there is something amazing and great about feeling connected to other people, for instance,
我们的理性永远无法顾及所有方面。有时，我们的行为可能拥有完美的理由，却对我们的归属感或连接感造成了极大的损害。我们没有被教导如何将这种理性与以下问题平衡起来：好吧，当你是对的时候，感觉是什么样的？你知道的，当你展示你的模型是正确的模型时，感觉是什么样的？我想，这里有一个试探性的说法，即事情需要改变的信号往往是一个感官信号。这就是那种感觉，例如，与其他人建立连接有着某种惊人而美好的感觉，
and to feel that rupture and realize that something's wrong, no matter how right you are symbolically and logically, that's a really powerful motivator to put down your model for a little bit and think about like, you know, what am I assuming here? Yeah, and you think about so many, you know, both interpersonal disagreements as well as, you know, partisan disagreements that we have. So much of that is about, you know, my map versus your map, as opposed to asking, how does this affect the relationship between me and you? Yeah, I really think, I mean, what many of us want, and I can say definitely what I want is to feel connected and loved and accepted by other people.
去感受那种断裂并意识到出了问题，无论你在象征意义和逻辑上是多么正确，这都是一个非常强大的动力，能让你暂时放下你的模型，思考一下，你知道的，我在这里假设了什么？是的，你想想很多，你知道的，既有人际分歧，也有我们之间的党派分歧。其中很大一部分都是关于，你知道的，我的地图对你的地图，而不是去问，这对我俩之间的关系有什么影响？是的，我真的认为，我的意思是，我们许多人想要的，我绝对可以说我想要的是感受到与其他人的连接、被爱和被接纳。
And that's a real feeling, right? In the times that I am most satisfied with my life, I feel like I have that connection and it's able to be there reliably. And the times that I've felt at my lowest is when I feel like alone. Not to be too melodramatic, like Shankar we just met, but I can feel a connection right now as we speak. And that's motivating me to open up more and share more. And it's meaningful. And I just feel like we don't even have a great vocabulary for that. We're not taught that to the same extent
那是一种真实的感觉，对吧？在我对生活最满意的那些时刻，我感觉自己拥有那种连接，并且它能够稳固地存在。而我感觉跌入谷底的时刻，则是当我感到孤独的时候。虽然不想表现得太戏剧化，尚卡尔，我们才刚见面，但此时此刻在说话的当下，我也能感受到一种连接。这正激励着我敞开心扉、分享更多。这是有意义的。我只是觉得我们甚至没有一个很好的词汇来表达这一点。我们没有被教导这一点，其程度就像
we're taught math or spelling. And we don't have a culture that checks in on that feeling of connection or disconnection as being as important as maybe some of our outward indicators of health and success. I really think it's this felt sense of connection both to ourselves in the world, but by extension to other people, to other living beings that's often missing when people feel like life has gone awry somehow. The solution, Norm says, is to deliberately and consistently reconnect with the world of the senses. To feel, to hear, to see. The more attentive we are of our bodies,
我们被教导数学或拼写那样。我们也没有一种文化，把对连接或断开连接这种感觉的关注，看得和我们健康和成功的某些外在指标一样重要。我真的认为，当人们觉得生活不知何故出了差错时，往往缺失的就是这种对自己与世界的连接感，进而延伸到对其他人、对其他所有生物的切身感受。诺姆说，解决办法是有意识且持续地与感官世界重新连接。去感受、去听、去看见。我们对身体越是专注，
the less likely we are to get trapped inside our internal, outdated maps. Norm says he has embraced a tactile practice each morning to help him be present with his family instead of letting the models inside his head tell him how to behave. You know, in the morning when I am tired and grumpy, I needed something that would just break right through and remind me that I had some intentions about how I You know, in the morning when I am tired and grumpy, I needed something that would just
我们就越不可能被困在内在的、过时的地图中。诺姆说，他每天早晨都会进行一种触觉练习，以帮助自己与家人保持当下，而不是让脑海中的模型告诉他该如何行事。你知道，在早晨当我疲惫而又暴躁时，我需要某种能够直接切入并提醒我有些关于我该如何……你知道，在早晨当我疲惫而又暴躁时，我需要某种能够直接
break right through and remind me that I had some intentions about how I wanted to be in the world. So what I learned to do is associate the feeling of cold tiles on my bathroom floor touching my feet with a reminder that I can be intentional about my relationships. And I've used that especially in times I felt really calcified in my relationships. If I'm stuck in a pattern where I'm getting into quarrels with my kids, for instance,
切入并提醒我有些关于我想要如何在世上生活的意图的东西。所以我学会做的是，将浴室地板上冰冷的瓷砖触碰我双脚的感觉，与一个提醒联系起来，即我对自己的关系可以是有意图的。每当我感觉自己在人际关系中变得非常僵化时，我尤其会使用这种方法。例如，如果我陷入了与孩子们争吵的模式中，
then I would use touching those tiles in the morning as a way to remember like today's a new day, it's a chance to look at things differently. Like, can you stay open right now? I understand that there was a morning recently when you and your kids were running behind schedule and you felt yourself getting increasingly angry. This had happened before and your mental maps were saying, you know, they never listened to me, were always running late.
那么我就会利用早晨触摸这些瓷砖的方式来提醒自己：今天是新的一天，这是一个以不同眼光看待事物的好机会。比如，你现在能保持开放的心态吗？我理解不久前的一个早晨，你和孩子们时间紧迫，你感到自己越来越生气。这以前也发生过，你的心智地图在说，你知道的，他们从来不听我的，我们总是迟到。
Describe what was happening in your mind and what you did at that point, Noor. Yeah, so I pride myself on being an engaged parent and I want my kids to learn about punctuality and I have a model that like I should be able to get them to school on time. And I would find that, you know, the harder I pushed them to get ready, the more they would kind of flop around and be playful and bicker with each other. And I would just be losing my mind. Like I would feel like this rage building up, this frustration of like, why won't you do this basic thing for me?
诺姆，请描述一下你当时的心态以及你做了什么。是的，所以我为自己是一个投入的父母而感到自豪，我希望我的孩子们能懂得守时，我有一个模型，即我应该能让他们按时去学校。我发现，你知道的，我越是催促他们准备好，他们就越是磨蹭、玩闹、互相争吵。而我简直要疯了。我能感到这种愤怒在积聚，这种挫败感涌上心头：为什么你们不为我做这件基本的事情？
Like, don't you even care about me? And at the same time, I have like a meta rage, but like, but I'm studying mindfulness. I'm supposed to be open to these things and just like, let the feeling go. And so I noticed like, okay, I'm just going to notice my rage. And then like three seconds later, it'd be like, get your like freaking shoes on. Right? Like, so just like attending to the rage and being open to the feeling of anger actually wasn't just going to take care of this problem. What I needed to do was actually be more exploratory.
就像，难道你们一点都不在乎我吗？与此同时，我还有一种元愤怒，就像是，可是我在研究正念。我应该对这些事情保持开放，然后只是，让这种感觉过去。所以我注意到，好吧，我只是去注意我的愤怒。然后大约三秒钟后，又会变成：快把你们那双鬼鞋穿上！对吧？所以，仅仅是关注愤怒并对愤怒的感觉保持开放，实际上并不能解决这个我面临的问题。我真正需要做的是变得更有探索精神。
And I remember like looking at my kids and being like, they don't care about getting to school on time. They just want to play. And I was like, well, what's it like to feel like you want to play? And feeling this kind of warmth and this sparkle again of, instead of rejection of them, sort of othering them as people who are thwarting my plans, feeling like, well, I want to be connected to them.
我记得我看着我的孩子们，心想：他们根本不在乎是不是能按时到校。他们只想玩耍。我当时就在想，那种想要玩耍的感觉是什么样的？然后重新感受到这种温暖和活力，不再去拒绝他们、把他们当作阻挠我计划的外人，而是觉得，嗯，我想和他们建立连接。
I want to play too, but we also have to get to school. And then realizing, well, I wanna be connected to them, I wanna play too, but we also have to get to school. And then realizing like, well, then really what I just need to do is get them out the door with this kind of feeling of connection and playfulness. Like, how could I do that? I bet you if like a big scary monster showed up and was threatening to tickle them,
我也想玩，但我们还得去学校。然后我意识到，好吧，那我真正需要做的，就是带着这种连接感和玩闹的心情让他们出门。我该怎么做到这一点呢？我敢打赌，如果出现了一个巨大的、可怕的怪物，威胁要胳肢他们，
they would be really motivated to get out the door, but it wouldn't be like angry dad time. So I felt the anger, but I also felt this connection to my kids. And I learned to become this kind of tickle monster when they were kind of messing around getting out the door. And eventually they started to be like, oh, he's turning to the tickle monster, get your shoes on really quick because you're going to get tickles. And it was like a totally different way around the problem that wasn't about being stricter, having more consequences or lecturing them about responsibility or other things that little kids just don't care about
他们就会有很强的动力出门，但这不会是那种充满愤怒的爸爸时间。所以，我感受到了愤怒，但我也感受到了与孩子们的这种连接。当他们在门口磨蹭时，我学会了变成这种“胳肢怪物”。最终他们开始说：“哦，他要变成胳肢怪物了，快点穿鞋，不然你要被胳肢了。”这是一种完全不同的解决问题的方法，不再是关于变得更严格、设定更多后果、或者对他们长篇大论地谈论责任或其他小孩子根本不在乎、
and are actually connection disrupting. So yeah, foraging isn't as simple as just like, if you get into sensation, all your problems are solved. It's the beginning of starting to explore, right? And then remembering like, what are you actually exploring for here? Like, are you willing to be surprised that the way to get this kind of connection, the way to have this feeling of positivity, it's not the way you expected it to look. But it's probably available
实际上只会破坏连接的事情。所以，是的，寻找方法并不像“只要你进入感官状态，所有问题就都解决啦”那么简单。这只是开始探索的起点，对吧？然后要记住：你在这里到底在探索什么？比如，你是否愿意惊讶地发现，获得这种连接的方式、获得这种积极感觉的方式，并不是你所预期的那种样子。但它很可能是可以得到的，
if you're willing to let go of what you know and try other things. Norman Farb is a psychologist and neuroscientist at the University of Toronto. With Zindel Siegel, he's the author of Better in Every Sense, how the new science of sensation can help you reclaim your life. In our companion story on Hidden Brain Plus, we look at a series of techniques to put us in closer touch with our senses. We will look at how to combat phobias and how to deal with recurring pain. If you're a subscriber to Hidden Brain Plus, that episode should be available in your feed right now.
只要你愿意放下已知的东西去尝试别的方法。诺曼·法布是多伦多大学的心理学家和神经科学家。他和齐德尔·西格尔合著了《全方位变好：感官的新科学如何帮您重塑生活》。在我们《隐藏的大脑》加长版的配套报道中，我们探讨了一系列能让我们与感官更紧密接触的技术。我们将探讨如何克服恐惧症以及如何应对反复发作的疼痛。如果你是《隐藏的大脑》加长版的订阅者，该期节目现在应该已经在你的动态中更新了。
It's titled, Making Sense. If you're not yet a subscriber, you can sign up for a free seven-day trial at apple.co. slash hidden brain or through our patreon membership page at support.hiddenbrain.org. Norm, thank you so much for joining me today on Hidden Brain. Thanks so much for having me. It's been wonderful to get to share these ideas. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media, our audio production team wonderful to get to share these ideas.
它的标题是《感官意义》。如果你还不是订阅者，可以在 apple.co 网站斜杠 hidden brain 注册七天免费试用，或者通过我们的 Patreon 会员页面 support.hiddenbrain.org 订阅。诺姆，非常感谢你今天来到《隐藏的大脑》。非常感谢邀请我。分享这些想法真是太棒了。《隐藏的大脑》由 Hidden Brain Media 制作，我们的音频制作团队分享这些想法真是太棒了。
Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our audio production team includes Annie Murphy-Paul, Kristen Wong, Laura Quarell, Ryan Katz, Autumn Barnes, Andrew Chadwick, and Nick Woodbury. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor. We end today with a story from our sister show, My Unsung Hero. This My Unsung Hero segment is brought to you by Discover. Our story comes from Jesuit priest Jim Martin.
《隐藏的大脑》由 Hidden Brain Media 制作。我们的音频制作团队包括安妮·墨菲-帕尔、克里斯汀·王、劳拉·夸雷尔、莱恩·卡茨、奥特姆·巴恩斯、安德鲁·查德威克和尼克·伍德伯里。塔拉·博伊尔是我们的执行制片人。我是《隐藏的大脑》的执行编辑。最后，我们以来自我们姐妹节目《我默默无闻的英雄》的一个故事结束今天的节目。《我默默无闻的英雄》这一板块由 Discover 赞助播出。我们的故事来自耶稣会神父吉姆·马丁。
In 2000, Jim's father was diagnosed with lung cancer. One of the people he will never forget from that time was a nun named Janice Farnham. Janice was one of Jim's professors in theology school and had become a family friend. She had a special fondness for Jim's father. And right before he died, Janice said to me, well, I'd like to come visit him. Now she lived in Boston and you know she's on a Catholic sister's budget, right, they take a vow of poverty. And Janice got on a train, took the train down five hours to Philadelphia, took another commuter train, found her way to the hospital, spent time with my dad, got
2000年，吉姆的父亲被诊断出患有肺癌。在那段时期，有一个人是他永远不会忘记的，她是一位名叫珍妮斯·法纳姆的修女。珍妮斯是吉姆在神学院的教授之一，后来成了家族的朋友。她对吉姆的父亲有着特殊的喜爱。就在他去世前不久，珍妮斯对我说，嗯，我想去探望他。当时她住在波士顿，而且你知道她拿着天主教修女的预算，对吧，她们发过贫困愿。珍妮斯坐上火车，坐了五个小时的火车来到费城，又换乘了一列通勤列车，找到了去医院的路，和我爸爸待了一会儿，然后又
back on the train and went back home. And I thought it was one of the nicest things that anyone has ever done for me. And I said, you know, I can't believe you didn't. She said, of course, you know, why wouldn't I wanna come down and see your dad? So this just really gracious, generous gesture of love and the fact that a Catholic sister would come down and visit my dad was a big deal for him. gracious, generous gesture of love.
坐上火车回到了家。我认为这是任何人对我做过的最好的事情之一。我对她说，你知道，我真不敢相信你没……她说，当然了，你知道的，我为什么不想来看看你爸爸呢？所以这是一种非常优雅、慷慨的爱意表达，而且一位天主教修女居然能特意来探望我爸爸，这对他的意义重大。优雅、慷慨的爱意表达。
And the fact that a Catholic sister would come down and visit my dad was a big deal for him. It was very moving. And I think it prepared him for, you know, his death, he died, I think, a week or two later. So I think it's a reminder that, you know, someone said 99% of life is showing up, and that these gestures that we make really stick with people.
而且一位天主教修女居然能特意来探望我爸爸，这对他的意义重大。这非常感人。我想这也让他为自己的死亡做好了准备，你知道的，他在一周或两周后去世了。所以我觉得这提醒了我们，你知道的，有人说过生活有99%在于出席，而我们做出的这些手势确实能深深留在人们心中。
You know, one of my rules now in life is when it comes to funerals or weddings or baptisms or certainly visiting people in the hospital or anything like that, if I can go, I will go. Right? If I'm able to go, if I'm there, I will go. And never underestimate that what we call in the Jesuits, ministry of presence, just showing up. Jim Martin is a Jesuit priest.
你知道，我现在的原则之一是，每当遇到葬礼、婚礼、洗礼，或者是去医院探望病人诸如此类的事情时，如果我能去，我就会去。对吧？如果我有能力去，如果我在场，我就会去。永远不要低估我们在耶稣会中所说的“陪伴的艺术”，也就是仅仅去到现场。吉姆·马丁是一名耶稣会神父。
He lives in New York City. His unsung hero, Jonas Farnham, is a retired professor of church history. This segment of My Unsung Hero was brought to you by Discover. Discover believes everyone deserves to feel special and celebrates those who exhibit the spirit in their communities. I'm a long-standing card member myself. Learn more at discover.com slash credit card. For more Hidden Brain, be sure to check out our free newsletter. In every issue, we bring you the latest research on human behavior. Plus, we always include
他住在纽约市。他默默无闻的英雄珍妮斯·法纳姆是一位退休的教会历史教授。《我默默无闻的英雄》这一板块由 Discover 赞助播出。Discover 相信每个人都值得感受到自己很特别，并赞美那些在社区中展现这种精神的人。我自己也是一名长期的信用卡会员。请访问 discover.com/credit-card 了解更多信息。想收听更多《隐藏的大脑》节目，请务必查看我们的免费时事通讯。在每一期中，我们都会为你带来关于人类行为的最新研究。此外，我们总是包含
a brain teaser and a moment of joy. You can sign up at news.hiddenbrain.org. That's n-e-w-s dot hiddenbrain dot org. I'm Shankar Vedantam. See you soon. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
一个脑筋急转弯和一个快乐时刻。你可以在 news.hiddenbrain.org 注册。网址是 n-e-w-s 点 hiddenbrain 点 o-r-g。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。我们回头见。本集节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。